[Music]
hello hello hello great I just want to
maximize the time before I have to catch
this flight to Atlanta so thank you for
listening please grab your food
I see where the mics are to see it so
there's three people that I'm sorry I'm
just getting context all right
why do we go go ahead sir what's your
name and what's your question look I
think even if your point the evolution
of crowdfunding gets harder and not as
wild wild west and it changes the
dynamics it's hard now like you know
crowdfunding is you know is really
fascinating cuz people get excited when
they hear about the one startup that
gets like a million dollars or a bunch
of people but like 98 99 % of
crowdfunded companies that are posted
don't reach their goals or get to learn
they're at so my answer is this it will
be a model that I genuinely believe will
always be out there because it's native
to the internet right we're more
connected it makes sense but I think
it's gonna come down to the thing that
it always comes down to which is I'm not
against it I like it I like it the same
way as pitching a high net worth
individual to give you a million dollars
for the piece you know it's there's a
million different ways we're living in
the newer now where people don't go to
the bank for a loan anymore and that was
the only way we did it in 1989 so things
will evolve and funding I think it's a
viable platform
I wouldn't overly worried about what its
gonna look like in 2027 and I would just
focus on what you're doing right now if
you like it if you have a knack for it
if you're good at it I think you milk it
and squeeze it but you recognize they'll
be evolutions
go ahead my man over here is in Phoenix
are over on this side of the room thank
you yep how much how much how much time
are you spending speaking to those
individuals one by one what about before
then how many employees do you have
yeah so to me the fact that you've
decided to make this your question I'm
jumping ahead cuz it's awesome and easy
how many partners do you have two right
so three total yeah the fact that
there's only ten employees per or eleven
employees per person you need to go
all-in bro you need to you need to do a
once a month with ten of the employees
breakfast you need to then take the
other ten and meet with them every month
like in the beginning of Vayner before
it got to like so many that I knew that
I just couldn't scale I was really
sticky DMing them like being a boss is
about and being an owner is about
reverse engineering your employees not
them conforming to you if you're upset
about the revolving door and that's
affecting you you need to figure out how
to get stickier the way to get stickier
is to figure out if it's my for the
acknowledgement title like what makes
them tick the you know it might just be
an extra dollar an hour on on that level
right or it might just be the fact that
you even gave a [ __ ] to take them out
for a coffee that made them stay an
extra 18 months an employee told me
flat-out that buying him Saint Louis
Cardinal it's early in his career at
Vayner made him pass on other offers
offering him 40 thousand more a year so
everybody here's you know and and think
about your lives right now if you've
been in the workforce or career there's
been times where you valued money more
there's been times where you wanted
worse
back more reputation balance it's not
only figuring out what the six things
are it's the six things today which is
why it never ends yep
[Music]
[Music]
a couple it's a really interesting
question and like I don't want to answer
it with this many people in the room
you'll appreciate where I'm about to go
it breaks down to a couple things number
one the reason I don't hear that back to
getting high on my supply the answer is
yes like people like Gary do you even
know how many people you're affecting
I'm like yes I get [ __ ] 10,000 emails
a week of people telling me that they
were about to commit suicide and stopped
because of my content or they were in
debt and now they're not or they used to
be mean to their wife and now they have
the best relations like so the answer is
like I think I'm gonna impact every
person on earth if I'm lucky enough to
live long enough which is a look
ludicrous thing to say it's unbelievably
audacious I genuinely at this point want
to be the most impactful human ever why
not why not why not but the reason it's
palpable and not obnoxious is because
when I hear that compliment that's a
much bigger compliment to my parents and
America than it is to me I'm a byproduct
of circumstance so so I don't lose my
way because I don't think it's me you
know does that make sense
Thank You Ben let's go you're making
content bro you also must have saw my
blog post a couple months ago about
wearing ridiculous shirts let's go baby
the video my got to say go figure I'm in
the financial advisory Lenexa cleaning
industries what did you see as the
future of that industry it's less about
what's the future it's more about you're
right on it like you need to make more
content bro like if you don't have a
very serious Linkedin content strategy
you're leaving a huge opportunity you're
young dude and you're gonna gravitate
towards IG video easy but LinkedIn is
[ __ ] gold right now for everybody
LinkedIn organic Reach is more
split-spoke organic reach was doing five
or six years ago it is just an
opportunity and I don't care if you're
selling weird t-shirts figure out how to
make it business oriented in LinkedIn
everybody here should really think about
how to make their content work to
professionals if you're in the roofing
business like title the posts why
lawyers and and and HR executives need
better roofs I'm not joking so I for you
bro heavy content a LinkedIn before
LinkedIn's organic reach starts
declining to high
thank you did you notice that I replied
to your tweet just just just a like this
is a funny meta moment because I think
it could be like a learning moment to
like truth like living your truth I'm
jumping in and interrupting her because
while I was walking from the stage to
here I replied to her tweet that she
just posted about me keeping it real on
stage today I I I drink my own kool-aid
when I yell at you for not replying to
your 13 comments on your last Instagram
post it's coz still at this point with
hundreds of thousands of comments I'm
living it alright I'm [ __ ] saw on
stage I'll get to a Jesus
good okay okay what I've seen is the
combination where I've made my money and
where I've lost my money is on the Delta
of the two things that matter the idea
and then the timing of that idea which
you're gonna deal with with AI and then
honestly the thing that in the beginning
I was great at but then I did get a
little too high on my supply off the
winds and I started just betting on the
idea I was at my best and I'm back to
being that person when I bet on the
person to like I can't I look the other
way you know what I did poorly I would
hear a business idea and I could dream
what I would do if I was running it and
that's when I thought it would be good
but I didn't realize like I'm not
running it and so what makes the success
in my opinion is I believe any idea the
ideas timing is right because that's
where people get killed like AI is gonna
happen when AR is gonna happen when you
know me people pour tons of money into
virtual reality 18 months ago we're not
even close
nobody here uses VR like so timing idea
human you're welcome where your 10
friends why are all your friends eating
I'm kidding I'm kidding
[Music]
yes it's the Knicks
you were gonna say maybe the last word
you see on the earth to pass on thank
you I am so fascinated by gratitude like
I'm so weirded out about human traits I
wonder you this is gonna make sense by
the way this is the downside of failing
science you're about to see it play out
because I'm asking you guys a question
I'm excited about thinking that the way
science is evolving like we'll be able
to go get not b12 shots but like
gratitude shots like besides health boy
would I wish for you to be
disproportionately empathetic and
grateful because if you are you will
live one happy life and so my answer
will be thank you because if I could
ever convince all of you that the
pontificating I do around 400 trillion
to 1 which is the current math that
scientists believe is the likelihood of
becoming a human being if you actually
sat here while you're eating your
[ __ ] salad and you actually let that
sink in like for a second I almost want
to go like Zen meditation [ __ ] and not
talk 400 trillion to one that you're a
human like how can't you be grateful for
the at-bat I'm just so grateful man I
would say thank you because I'm so
grateful like I feel Dec my whole life
nightmares as a kid today I think about
all the time out of one thing the love
of life and that's not much money I have
a followers it I just play my game
getting to thank you by the way getting
to play my game I just wanted to get
this last part out like that's what I
want I want people to play their a game
because you're also talking to someone
who played his game you're a shitty
student you're gonna suck I grew up
looking around the faces there's enough
people here remember the 80s and 90s and
even early 2000 that's the golden era of
good college is the only way you win
like like and then the world came to me
it wasn't cool to be an entrepreneur
there were entrepreneurs that had
t-shirt
the people war and then the world came
to me because I never wavered for my
place and so maybe you loved painting in
with tomatoes and maybe it seems
ridiculous today let me tell you how
many of my friends at 17 18 19 20 21
should have just stayed playing video
games and not trying to become a lawyer
they'd be making a lot more money and
being a lot happier today nobody over 40
in this room growing up the way I did
saw professional video game playing
being a profession all the moms told us
to get off the [ __ ] thing and go be
somebody who goes to college and takes
$300,000 in debt and never gets out of
debt like guys how many examples do you
want me to give you to tell you that you
don't know how life's gonna play out
it's why I love making choices I hate
when people like Gary I'm crippled like
what should I do this or this I'm like
pick one they're like uh I'm like if you
pick one you do understand you'll never
know what would have happened the reason
I don't struggle with making decisions
is because I know that I don't get to
see how it would have played out so I
don't know we need to get way more basic
but the answer is to you hi how are you
amazing you can
[Music]
just like building their business they
don't they're dead that's right but you
can't control the world from the grave
so though like are you asking what's the
best way to make sure my business is
being run properly once I'm gone well
that's the reason I'm so unbelievably
passionate about making content and
putting it on the Internet this question
an interaction that you and I are having
right now is being watched right now 47
years after my death I'm aware so you
want legacy produce content you want to
that pontificating I just did up there
about having a vlog and making content
it may not turn it into your million
dollar business I promise you you're
gonna have a real laugh with your
granddaughter in 39 viewers watching it
content you know people used to be lucky
that their great grandfather or
grandmother were famous and so there was
like old films about them and they had
things we didn't have we had like 1729
pictures like Mike like everybody in
this room should be the patriarch and
matriarch of their families in
perpetuity because they're the ones who
are now alive during the era of content
creation at scale and there should be
more content of you than anybody prior
to you thus you're the starting point
literally I genuinely believe what I'm
about to say this room is the starting
point for their family because in 130
years they're not going to know your
great-grandparents but you're going to
be that person so I would produce
content all right picture
yo how are you okay right no though the
grind of life is what we involve in so
my big thing with nonprofits is a couple
things and I sit on several boards that
spend a lot of time thinking about the
marketing of nonprofits the biggest
vulnerability for nonprofits is ideology
like it's very awesome that you're
passionate about this but he just might
not be and the ideology and even
audacity of some of the people that work
or run nonprofits is the thing I'm
trying to get them out of what I'm
trying to get the ones I'm involved with
is like cool let's not convince anybody
of anything
let's disproportionately create stories
and let the people that actually care
about them consume them and it's a very
important framework if you think about
how I just talked about that don't waste
a minute trying to convince somebody who
can't be commenced right I mean you know
this like I don't want you to be
disappointed anymore like that your
passion about it I'm passionate about
Crohn's and Colitis cuz my brother has
it like we can't judge like I love when
people judge like and that's what a lot
of nonprofits do just cuz you're a
[ __ ] nonprofit doesn't mean you're
owed anything it's amazing that you're
doing something amazing so now let's
focus on people who we think are right
and so I think it's about content
marketing and most importantly the
mindset when we go in
talk to people about being appreciative
to even get the at-bat to get them to
hear about it but baling really quick
like if I'm pitching him on hey we're
gonna have disability and I could see
his eyes are glossing thank you so much
man have a great day that's how I live
my life I don't expect anything from
anybody about anything I'm talking about
and the second I get an indicator that
that are not interested I'm not mad at
them I just want to move on to the next
thing because there's [ __ ] 400
million people to talk to it's a big
mindset shift for a lot of people profit
land you understand it's a big deal if
you really use that filter you'll be
stunned by the adjectives and words you
use on email phone call and social media
that will become the unlock for you
actually getting what you want makes
sense
cool you're welcome it's super important
that was an important moment for a lot
of people like when you change your
mindset back to the kind of like weird
thing I was doing on stage like once you
want like I could even see like where
she was like that was fine we want to
let her go because I could tell she's
like kind of getting it right and it's
supported to get it because it goes back
to entitlement when you're as wonderful
as she is and you're doing something so
important for the world you know and you
see people buying [ __ ] Lamborghinis
and [ __ ] $80.00 this and like you
know like and they don't have time for
you in this it's very easy to start to
judge but that becomes your downfall and
when you don't have expectations and
when you're not entitled well we're
nonprofit you should you should but I
hear that so much in nonprofit boards
I'm in you should you should what it's
not like we're sitting down with you for
four you might have a sick grandmother
that you like have to take a percentage
fee or paycheck to just cuz you're like
you should do nothing you should be a
decent human being but how that
manifests right and everyone's posturing
it doesn't take much to put out a tweet
that says hashtag me too but how are you
actually living your life got it so we
need to eliminate entitlement and
judgment once you do that you're in
giving mode not expecting mode once
you're in giving mode a very funny thing
happens
you start getting its now how many likes
or followers you get its how much value
you bringing to the people who decided
to follow you in the first place
all of a sudden a funny thing happens
all of a sudden the nine people that
give a [ __ ] about you today
tell seven other people because you
actually gave a [ __ ] back for them
giving a [ __ ] in the first place
Hey yes by holding them accountable to
respect but not creating an ideology of
what respect is right where I think
people struggle is they've decided to
manifest what respect is the thing that
I've been so fascinated by the world on
is for some reason we've decided that
writing a letter to somebody and sending
it is some greater act than sending a
text with the same words on it we are
that the reason we're [ __ ] on kids
today is cuz they don't look you in the
eye when you shake their hand like the
key is actually understanding what is
actual respect and kindness not the
current state of what's politically
correct in its manifestation that's it
so you know that's how I'm you know I'm
really paying attention to what my two
are doing and watching everybody else
like I hate when people like these kids
they don't know how to socialize they're
more social than we were these kids go
online and socialize with hundreds of
kids on Twitch and Instagram and YouTube
all day what did you do on a random
Wednesday in 1986 let me remind you you
threw a rock in the [ __ ] water
like it's crazy like we [ __ ] on the new
generation and we put our generation on
an ideology do you know what my
contemporary girlfriend and Friends that
were brought in in high school they ran
into the room lock the door got on their
second phone line and we're on the phone
for a second seven [ __ ] hours before
they went to sleep sounds like being on
your phone all day judgment so you know
what you're you're their mom you know
what respect is if you became
ideological and you said shaking a
person's hand like fine that's that's up
to you I will never tell anybody to
parent but I will tell you
socially commentating on the macro old
people start putting old [ __ ] on a
pedestal and that's some [ __ ] do you
remember the outrage of Miley Cyrus's
VMA appearance seven years ago that's
like a lame Instagram post like go read
what we wrote about the Beatles long
hair and the extreme disrespect it was
to our society don't get old
stop being full of [ __ ]
Hey yes number one is a lot of your
languages reinforces two things so
upstairs we reinforced 7,000 people due
to post the sponsorship yes and not
qualified but it's good contact her
echoes to just
ridiculousness correct then the second
thing that potentially I want to please
forcing especially on this list but this
thing is I find myself questioning yes I
think intent I think one of the reasons
I've been able to curse maybe more than
others is because I think humans are
actually unbelievably good at having
intuition around intent and I think for
a lot of people they're like if I had to
bet my life on it
that's just the Jersey boy being Jersey
boy not somebody who's trying to use it
to be I mean brother like the other
thing is the truth go watch my videos on
YouTube that I posted in two thousand
nine ten eleven
I get destroyed for cursing go oh he
seems not like I wish my VA a you know
we just started a speaking Bureau where
Zach who was my CAA rep is now my seat I
wish she was here right now to tell you
how much money I lost in two thousand
nine ten eleven twelve and how they
would beg me they would say thing I mean
they were trying to bribe me they were
like we've got five hundred thousand in
advance five speeches when I was making
thirty thousand of speech so this is a
big jump a hundred thousand speech but
you can't curse and like this and it
needs to be like the beginning of you
not cursing and I was like [ __ ] you
because I'll tell you where it is my
friend I think you'll understand this
and I think I can tell why you picked up
on that its intent I'm not cursing for
the sake of cursing this is how I'm
comfortable and communicating as a
matter of fact I wish I get it because I
would be bigger you know the the Alpha
young males I would have them without it
but all the people I'm losing because I
cursed the amount of people that judge
me and think I'm a bad person because I
curse would be staggering to you you
just have the capability of seeing
through that and seeing the truth and
the humanity like if I spoke with a
little less energy a little less bravado
a little less Jersey and a lot less
cursing I would be seven times bigger
it's not about boring just it wouldn't
be me it just wouldn't it's not even
exciting you can be better like I watch
a lot of stand-up comedy you can like
there's great people who don't it's just
not my truth it's I don't know the tip
to be honest um I so don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on out there cuz I can't
hear anything I don't know who speaks I
don't guys I've never seen Tony Robbins
speaking this lot like I don't consume
content your content your content right
I don't consume other people's books or
podcasts or shows I just feed your
comments that's how I know stuff you
think I just lucked into having great
understanding of human behavior this is
[ __ ] twenty years of just reading
every single princes point of view on
every single goddamn thing at scale of
course I'm gonna be good at
trend-spotting its pattern recognition
of what's made people tick we don't
change the landscape changes we're
animals that's why I know how insecure
we are that's why I laugh when you guys
blame social media for what's going on
it's the mirror blame a traditional
media that lists in a world where we
know that this is the step backwards for
the two steps forward we've got to
reconcile our shortcomings it's being
exposed so you know I don't want to you
know to be frank I'm not pumped on
Bolger
nope riding first thing I don't think
it's cool I really don't I really don't
I just think it's me and I don't know
how to be anything but me you want a
real life lesson figure that out [ __ ]
gets good yeah I do I think what's going
on okay thank you brother
nope
I draw line and I like thank God you
have the second part and now I will try
to suffocate you in perpetuity to not
give a [ __ ] about the first part people
spend all their time on defense and
that's why they lose are you gonna chase
them down like what what are you gonna
slip into their DM and be like you're a
dick what are you gonna spend nine hours
trying to figure out where that person
lives and call them like what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do you know what I would
do if it's bothering you so much leave a
comment on that post to be like yo bro
thanks so much for using my image do it
every time and never worry about
somebody stealing your image because
stealing images in a 20-19 internet
world is different than 1974 in print
form it's a different game cool thank
you everyone
[Applause]